I mentioned earlier purpose-driven and
then David interjected off-camera
intuitive confidence and I actually like
that better I think I can see that in
you too where does that come from well
it's undeniable you get a feeling in
your stomach and if you can't sleep
you're so electrified you your nervous
system is just lit up and you know that
you're gonna make a film about this idea
you've had it's happened to me three
times in my life and each time it did
turn into a film the first time I saw
Peter Dirk Ace this famous South African
political satirist I saw him at the
Sydney Opera House and he was talking
about how he'd gone all over South
Africa and he'd seen a million school
kids educating them about HIV and AIDS
and I just put myself in their shoes
these kids that were my age at the time
and it was just like I have to tell the
story I have to go to South Africa I
have to make a film about this person it
was undeniable and that turned into
darling that Peter Dirk a story it
happened with cuppa dreams my second
film and again with Sierra I mean I'm
not like exaggerating this or making
this into a story for you when I went on
her website I knew I was gonna make a
movie about her I didn't know what it
was I had no idea but I just got this
feeling and believe me I've had a lot of
ideas along the way that never turned
into anything I've had a lot of scripts
that weren't quite good enough to get
made but if you really get that gut
feeling you owe it to yourself to follow
it and and as time goes on I'm more and
more tuned into that feeling rather than
rationalizing that intellectualizing it
just like does this hit me on a gut
level
yeah and that gives me confidence
because I feel it in the pit of my
stomach
and then I can convey that to other
people and get them to join me on the
journey and help me do it
yeah what about when people try to talk
you out of your experience because for
people that everybody's intuitive
everyone but some people have like a
higher level whether it's just from
meditation or yoga whatever and then
there's people that kind of talk you out
of your experience and say oh no you're
just being whatever or I don't know if
this will work no for sure and look at
the end of the day it just it either
happens or it doesn't I mean you know
you go into it with full confidence and
people will either respond or they won't
so
them a little bit fatalistic isn't the
right word but you just keep making the
effort you keep trying and if it is a
good enough idea it will get made if it
does resonate with people it will happen
and if it doesn't then sadly it just it
won't happen it'll be too hard but at
the end of the day it is all on you when
you're the like writer-director you're
the one driving it for years so you need
to feel strong enough that you've got
that energy which lasts years to keep
pushing it along and if you look inside
and you feel like the energy maybe isn't
there you need to ask yourself is that a
story I really want to tell for any of
your three films was there ever a point
where you almost gave up absolutely my
second film cup of Dreams was a total
nightmare really proud of the film super
personal film it's about New Zealanders
obsession with rugby it's a bit like
Canadiens and hockey or Brazilians and
soccer it's a national obsession when
the New Zealand rugby team like loses in
a World Cup the economy takes a fall
people go into therapy all right it is
the psyche of the country is connected
to how this team does luckily they're a
really good team but um I was an old
black fan because I grew up in New
Zealand so I love these guys but I was
too close to it I actually loved rugby
too much and I started making not a very
good film right and it just ran out of
steam the funding dried up and I was
depressed and I was like okay I just
spent all my savings trying to make this
documentary I'm broke in fact I'm in
debt
I got no idea what's next and then my
producer Jonathan green he kind of
picked me up but he gave me some tough
love and he kind of said look the reason
it didn't work out is because you're too
close you love this topic too much you
need some objectivity and so then he
helped me step back realise why do I
really love rugby oh it's actually these
personal reasons and it's about my
relationship with my father and he
helped me delve deeper and that turned
it into a film that wasn't about sport
it became a film about people and
relationships and home and it connected
with an audience who may have
of rugby but they got it so I would say
sometimes you need a little bit of
distance from your subject right it's
good to be passionate but if if you are
so in love with it that you can't see
the wood for the trees that's not
necessarily a good thing so sometimes
you need people around you to give you
objectivity and use that because it will
help you and it will help you find the
story you really want to tell
you